[Musik]
für den schweizer militärpiloten andreas
kuhn ist es die krönung seiner
fliegerischen karriere bald startet und
landet er mitten im atlantik auf einem
amerikanischen flugzeugträger
das amerikanische ausbilder
zweitens das mit stoffen ist dass sie
mich zur traute sich das gelände hier
ist alles extrem die wetterbedingungen
die platzverhältnisse und die gefahren
verfolger das wird sehr sehr erstaunt
und sehr sehr herausfordernd
[Musik]
pöttinger beach an der us ostküste im
sommer ist der strand ein beliebtes
ferienziel für amerikaner
die stadt selbst könnte irgendwo in den
usa liegen
[Musik]
ein eigentliches stadtzentrum gibt es
nicht zu fuß ist hier kaum jemand
unterwegs
virginia beach lebt vor allem vom
militär der größte teil der bevölkerung
arbeitet für die us navy so auch andreas
kuhn
vor gut zwei jahren ist der 37 jährige
luzerner mit seiner familie hierher
gezogen in eine umgebung die so ganz
anders ist als die schweiz jetzt gefühl
in eine stadt habe wohl nicht gleich
erkannt dass das nicht da nicht das ist
ja wunderbar für die audio das aber so
dass das heimelige eine vom lebensgefühl
h
das
da sind wir aktuell gerade der schweiz
dafür komme man sich hier weniger in die
quere als zu hause in der schweiz wo man
dafür in gewissem rahmen einfach das
leben und leben lassen wo was ich damals
keine große vorne schieben und effektiv
sagt wird die nachbarschaft aber es ist
da stört es auch nicht wenn am sonntag
am morgen
[Musik]
kuhn lebt mit seiner frau und den drei
kindern am stadtrand auf einem kleinen
insel streifen dann nur durch eine
brücke mit dem festland verbunden ist
hier in den usa absolvierte ein
austauschprogramm zwischen der schweizer
luftwaffe und der us- neben als
fluglehrer bilder der amerikanische
piloten auf dem f a 18 kampfjet aus
andreas kuhn lebt seine leidenschaft das
fliegen bedeutet ihm alles sagt er
doch die familie stehe immer zuoberst wo
du schrieb ich für aktuelles programm
und ich jetzt teilnehmer durch seine ski
das hat die unbedingt machen ich habe
gewusst dass meine frau im boots- und
erst wenn das handy quasi wieder einmal
das wetter und die augen mal seit der
hobby halt mit ich okay gut für dich
sondern sie zeigt das wollte ich auch
machen
er ist noch da nicht doch ich tue mich
bewerbe führen das ist im sport
frau und kinder möchten lieber nicht
gefilmt werden deshalb steht kuhn für
einmal allein im großen garten
so wie ich ihn in seiner freizeit
erleben würde ich im ersten moment gar
nicht darauf kommen dass hier ein
kampfjet pilot am laub rechen ist kuhn
ist nicht die hollywood version eines
militärpiloten keine lederjacke keine
gel frisur ein schnittiges auto und
tatsächlich hatte kuhn als junger bub
andere pläne haben auch die touristen
und der gefangenen betreibt zwölf xi wo
man zuerst einmal mit der familie
vergleiche man den ferien geflogen das
sondern die guten alten zeiten wo man ok
man kann jetzt fix und alle knöpfe und
fasziniert und durch trial gefangen
der erste schritt eigentlich meine
mutter gemacht musste zeitig das inserat
für tv westrich vorschule vorgängers
verschnitt hätte mir das auf dem tisch
erklärte gesagt du dir mal was hätte
wohl der zwölfjährige andreas damals
gedacht wenn man ihm gesagt hätte dass
er einmal auf einem flugzeugträger
landen würde
sechs wochen lang hat kuhn nur noch
dafür trainiert das landen auf einer
ultra kurzen schwimmenden piste mitten
auf dem meer
wenn wir schon davon erzählt klingt er
fasziniert es sei ein höhepunkt sagt er
aber auch die anspannung wirklich immer
nur noch zwei tage bis zum
flugzeugträger und der druck nimmt zu
die dann mit lugo
doch dann habe ich es vor dem hat keine
neue situation
das heißt etwa cdu
richtig los geht es dann noch nervös
wird sie das ist klar aber das gehört
dazu
respekt hat dann eine gewisse nervosität
vor wichtigen ist auf jeden fall dass
ich habe aber gut vorbereitet hätten
[Musik]
noch ein tag bis zum flugzeugträger ein
letztes training steht an
das briefing übernimmt kuhn oder look
wer hier bei seinem piloten namen
genannt wird wetter anflugverfahren
frequenzen notfall abläufe im
schnelldurchlauf geht die gruppe das
wichtigste noch mal durch mir fällt auf
viele piloten tragen einen schnauz wie
kuhn das sei tradition in der ausbildung
für den flugzeugträger
[Musik]
besser wurde mit brille
das darf man das griechische gott dass
mir die leute relativ nicht der fall am
anfang die selektion stört wenn tagen
eine kurze aber es ist klar dass das mit
dem alter künstler liebt einfach der
geschlechter weiter ziemlich glückliche
jahre wie die damals vater ein bisschen
auf anfrage nicht zum autofahren nicht
zu schaffen im büro oder zum pflügen
große hilfe absolut dass ich gar auf 14
[Musik]
was ich das für das logo auf dem helm
das ist ein gladiator andreas kuhn trägt
das schweizer kreuz mit stolz er sagt er
könne sich gar nicht vorstellen ohne das
symbol seiner heimat abzuheben
das kreuz kommt auch auf den
flugzeugträger mit ein ort mit ganz
anderen verhältnissen als koons
heimatbasis in meiringen aber ist
überhaupt nicht vergleichbar mit der
schwierigkeit das bald aber auch in der
feststellung
die naval air station china ist riesig
allein in kunst staffel den gladiators
fliegen 110 kampfjets das sind doppelt
so viele wie in der gesamten schweizer
luftwaffe
viele der piloten die hier ausgebildet
werden fliegen schon bald kriegseinsätze
[Musik]
spezielle situation dass ich auf spitzen
aus neutraler die us-navy flüge
hättest du mir wenn du das doch gleich
das bild ist wenn du das müsste ich
gegen die bevölkerung einsetze
ich bin militärpilot aufgefallen
und wenn das der fall war dann würde ich
das halbstaatliche machen
aus gründen der neutralität darf kann
natürlich keine kriegseinsätze fliegen
aber als fluglehrer bereitet der piloten
auf ebensolche vorn
das austauschprogramm zwischen der
schweiz und den usa entstand vor über 20
jahren als die luftwaffe damals den f a
18 kampfjet kaufte ließ sie ihre
fluglehrer bei der navy umschulen
seither besteht die partnerschaft
gleichzeitig befindet sich immer auch
ein us pilot in der schweiz
jetzt kommt ruhe lassen wir visiten
einstige
richtig gewachsen immer noch einmal
guten stand sind wir konkurrenzfähig das
programm ist eine von den möglichkeiten
so was machen
die flugzeugträger qualifikation ist
dafür nicht zwingend nötig aber sie
gehörte von anfang an zum programm dazu
zur freude der schweizer piloten
der trainings auftrag am tag vor dem
großen moment lautet landungen geben
auf einem flugfeld etwas südlich der
basis ist auf der großen landebahn die
winzige piste des flugzeugträgers
aufgemalt im minuten-takt dröhnen die
jets an uns vorbei
andreas kuhn seine kollegen versuchen
immer wieder im richtigen winkel den
idealen aufsetzpunkt zu finden auf dem
flugzeugträger wir das dann noch
deutlich schwieriger nun spricht von
europa park feeling
ein sogenannter landing safety officer
beobachtet und bewertet jeden anfang er
entscheidet wer ein ticket für den
flugzeugträger bekommt
hier ist die kuh nicht mehr fluglehrer
sondern schüler
[Musik]
die usa streit die eisen haus ein
flugzeugträger angetrieben von zwei
atomreaktoren fast 6000 frauen und
männer arbeiten an bord dieses
gigantischen schiffes
[Musik]
über 80 flugzeuge finden hier platz
vor ein paar monaten noch befand sich
der flugzeugträger im persischen golf im
kampf gegen den es über 1000 bomben
wurden bei diesen missionen abgeworfen
die eindrücke auf dem flugzeugträger
erschlagen mich fast einerseits bin ich
fasziniert von diesem wunder der technik
andererseits wird mir an jeder ecke
bewusst dass dies ein kriegsschiff ist
eine große schwimmende waffe der usa
es ist das erste mal überhaupt dass ein
fernsehteam aus der schweiz bei
flugzeugträger qualifikationen mit an
bord ist nach zwei jahren der
vorbereitung ist es deshalb auch für
meinen kameramann und mich ein ganz
besonderer moment nun auf dem flugdeck
zu stehen und diesen film zu drehen
andreas kuhn ist einige stockwerke unter
deck einquartiert sich hier
zurechtzufinden braucht übung die langen
gänge die vielen leitern keine fenster
das macht die orientierung für besucher
nicht ganz einfach
aber kunst gedanken drehen sich nun um
seinen flug und dieser wird eine noch
größere herausforderung als erwartet
die dinge gehört jetzt not event normal
ist ein 25 bis 30 besonders vom training
auch gewöhnt sind anfangs mit
sogenannten apps auf der ladeklappe
nicht ganz ins gefahren und so viel wir
werden ein steiler nachwuchs winkelhaus
münchen vom training als er sich alles
klar gestellt dass man das denken kann
dass man morgen vielleicht dafür aber
das baby einfach genommen als der
aktuelle ich nicht dann machen wir das
kostbare
der start vom flugzeugträger erfolgt mit
einem katapult gestartet wird nämlich
auf einer strecke von nicht einmal 100
metern
das bugrad des flugzeugs rastet im
katapult einer der pilot gibt vollen
schub
und dann jagt das katapult den chat vom
schiff
die landung beschreiben die piloten als
kontrollierten absturz der chat muss
exakt aufsetzen damit der ausgefahrene
fang haken eines der kabel erwischt
welches das flugzeug dann gewaltsam
gestoppt
hier ist feingefühl gefragt
der pilot muss gleichzeitig wieder
vollgas geben für den fall dass er das
kabel bei der landung verpasst
[Musik]
im sogenannten redd beobachten die
wartenden piloten ihre kollegen via
bildschirm der moment rückt näher
die anspannung ist kommt nun deutlich
anzusehen
was dem kontrollturm weiß man um diesen
stress
wir müssen uns sehr konzentrieren denn
diese jungs machen das zum ersten mal
wir schauen hier dass wir alle sicher
unter plan wissen sie dass auch ein
schweizer pilot an bord
ja das habe ich gehört und wie ich höre
ist die schweizer marine fliegerei stark
am wachsen seien ernsthaft es ist toll
dass wir eure jungs trainieren können
die innerschweizer aber auch die briten
all unsere partner das ist wirklich toll
es ist soweit
bei tiefstehender sonne starkem wind und
wellengang besteigt der schweizer seine
f a 18
nun bin ich selber angespannt merke wie
ich mit comicfiguren jetzt wo der große
moment gekommen ist der start von einem
flugzeugträger
[Musik]
die navy erlaubt uns eine kleine kamera
im flugzeug zu platzieren
so haben wir die außergewöhnliche
möglichkeit direkt neben crew im cockpit
dabei zu sein
es ist eine beeindruckende perspektive
in unmittelbarer nähe starten und landen
kampfflugzeuge
während kuhn zur startposition genutzt
wird
[Musik]
ein letztes mal kontrolliert kuhn die
steuerung seines chefs
und dann geht's los
in zwei sekunden auf 2 170
stundenkilometern
es ist kaum zu hören aber kuhn just vor
erleichterung
[Musik]
der start ist geschafft
der schwierigste teil folgt aber erst
noch die landung
[Musik]
zuerst fliegt cool ohne fang haken dran
wie im training muss er beweisen dass er
den punktgenauen anflug beherrscht
diesmal aber auf einer piste die sich im
wasser auf und ab bewegen
der erste test gelingt es folgt der
zweite
[Musik]
punktgenau
und dann gilt es ernst
kuhn hat den fang haken ausgefahren im
licht der abenddämmerung nimmt er den
flugzeugträger ins visier
er setzt zur landung an
und verpasst alle von kabel
jetzt wirds eng nun muss es vor einbruch
der dunkelheit schaffen sonst muss er ab
drehen um noch rechtzeitig an land zu
fliegen
das ist es der schweizer landet erstmals
auf einem us-flugzeugträger gleich
danach treffen wir den überglücklichen
piloten unter deck
erster start auf dem flugzeugträger
wünschte sich unglaublich das ist
unbeschreiblich wirklich effektiv nicht
früher fand ich mal zeit europa das sich
dem leser sich vielfältige mit der ise
haben
und das ist absolut ja
aber genauso getan
[Musik]
ich freue mich für andreas kuhn die
ganze anspannung ist verflogen
er strahlt eine leichtigkeit und freude
aus wie ich sie bei ihm in den letzten
tagen nicht gesehen habe
[Musik]
und so verabschieden wir uns vom
schweizer auf dem flugzeugträger ein
knappes jahr noch bleibt er mit seiner
familie in den usa
dann kehrt er zurück in die schweiz und
auch wenn dieses abenteuer nur einen
kleinen teil seines austauschs bei der
us navy ausmacht es ist mit sicherheit
das prägendste erlebnis das starten und
landen auf einen flugzeugträger
[Musik]